in a previous interview you were a bit
critical about how heavily the civil
rights movement relied on the leadership
of Martin Luther King I was just
wondering what you think successful
leadership is whether it's supplemental
to these movements and how leaders can
contribute their time talent and
treasure to these movements without
being the sole propel our critique of
dr. King and remember we love dr. King
and we admired him a great deal we
thought he was bravery personified were
somebody worth following the our
critique of him was that he often
without meaning to said to local people
I'm going to take care of your problems
you don't have to worry about these
things I'll do it and I say this is not
something he was said this was something
they imputed to him and as a consequence
felt themselves less likely or less able
to join in helping themselves so
leadership is always a necessary
component of social change but that
leadership doesn't have to stifle and we
believe that dr. King's persona again
not through his own making but through
the eyes of others stifled their own
ability to act as leaders so with I
remember I was in a hotel in Atlanta
once having a meeting with dr. King and
passed by a bunch of maids in the
hallway and one of them said dr. King
just went by I know all our problems are
going to be solved now apparently they
had some dispute with the hotel but dr.
Cain was not there for their dispute
with the hotel although i'm sure he
sympathized with it he was there for
entirely different purposes but they had
transferred their responsibility to do
something about their condition to this
man who was just passing by so that's
our argument with him and again it was
not a personal argument with the persona
it was the argument with the people who
thought this of him and imputed to him
the ability to solve their problems